sometimes dark humor is funny and
sometimes it's not I think that it's
really important to dig into and figure
out like why certain things are funny
can't give you an example yeah go it's
from your subreddit oh boy no that made
me laugh and I felt wrong about it oh no
so this is uh
nine I already know what this is yeah
yeah
so this is a trolley problem to me it
connects because I I think about the TR
it keeps because I worked on autonomous
vehicles of the trolley problem the
philosophical thought experiment keeps
brought up a lot you know when AI is
part of making the decision do I kill
three people here or five people here
then AI makes a decision how do you do
that calculus and this this particular
there's a
there's a deep so satire that reveals
some kind of flaw in society I feel like
that's what dark camera does successful
dark humor does and I was a flaw I feel
like certain there's a certain brand of
dark humor and I think the reason I
think the reasons one is why it's good
or or why it is good humor I think it's
because I don't think it necessarily
reveals a flaw sometimes I feel like it
reveals like a kind of virtue I think
like if you look at this particular
thing can I explain what we're going for
oh yeah we're just listening uh the
titles of the Reddit post is you know
what to pick uh and it says uh five
people are going to die either way but
if you flip the lever the trolley will
do a sick [ __ ] Loop first
and also the top comment
is a question saying which I think is
also part of the document that's
successful can I get the gender and
ethnic backgrounds of the groups first
and the top answer is both groups are
each comprised of five white orphaned
CIS male
heavy meth users who are consistently in
and out of drug rehab all who identifies
right-wing extremists humor is so it's
such a sophisticated thing that we
engage in humor is like really
complicated
um but I would argue that like hopefully
the humor here shows the virtue of like
this is obviously horrible but that's
kind of why it's funny it's funny
because it's such a horrible question to
ask like do we kill five people in a
boring way or in a really entertaining
way and it's like that's really that's
really and then when you ask even more
like what are the ethnic backgrounds
like that's even worse to say that you
know so I feel like that's like the type
of there's a way that you can engage
with dark humor where it's like oof like
it's funny because it's so wrong and so
typical we all know that it's wrong in
taboo and that's kind of where the
shared laugh comes from so for me the
question that is asking the the
diversity question is a sophisticated
way of revealing the absurdity of asking
about diversity when it's talking about
human life oh interesting because the
way that I took that was I think it
reveals the absurdity of how people will
weigh different ethnic backgrounds so
differently when it comes to value of
human life like I'm actually thinking of
that in terms of like a an immigration
related question where people are really
keen and quick to dehumanize like black
or brown people so like the question is
like well if five of them are brown and
five are white well I know which one I'm
gonna you know pull the lever for that's
how I read that but it's satirizing that
aspect yeah exactly yes of course yeah
but that's what I mean that that's the
flaw to me at least it showed that
Humanity
or social networks that are easy to be
outraged and love the outrage and the
chaos
that Twitter and social networks will
pull that lever like they would they
would always try to maximize the fun and
there's like a there's a sick aspect to
all the atrocities all the tragedies
that happen in the world that we kind of
always lean towards the
um the outrageous narrative weaved
around it the
yeah the the one that leads to sort of
the most clicks to the most uh attention
to the most outraged to all the all that
kind of so that that's almost like a a
satire of society when they are faced
with tragedy
they will maximize trying to think of a
word that's not fun but entertainment
maximize the entertainment yeah this is
a big criticism I give especially to
conservative crowds
um you know left lane appeal everybody
doesn't I don't like when people blame
the media for the state of the media
today I very much believe that
everything in society is a feedback loop
and that if you're really unhappy with
the state of the media I think that the
media is a good reflection for what
people want to see because there is a
room right now in the United States
where somebody could start a company
where all they do is completely factual
reporting they don't have a political
slant and they're not giving you these
like sensationalist narratives or
stories and that Media Company would
fail in two weeks because people don't
want to see that generally people really
want to see the like show me the guy
that really believes in what I say that
calls the other guy an idiot the guys
that are screaming on TV or on the radio
like this is what I really want
um and people will engage in that and
that feedback loop will continue for
generations and then all of a sudden
people like why is the media so biased
why is the media driving so many
narratives I was like what do you mean
this is exactly what you want to see
and that's that's frustrating for me
that's one of my big kind of when I
defend establishments or when I talk
about like the interplay between Citizen
and
and all these institutions we have that
the institutions are very much a
reflection of the population at least in
Democratic societies and I think that
people very much try to elude the
personal responsibility or the country's
responsibility to why some of them look
the way that they do